INFORMANT WILL BE MADE
ACCESSIBLE.
>> Bret: CATHERINE HERRIDGE IN
WASHINGTON.
THANK YOU.
MORE ON THIS WITH THE PANEL.
TOP HOUSE REPUBLICANS AS
RUSSIA'S GOAL IS TO CREATE CHAOS
DURING THE UPCOMING MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
HOW TO PREVENT THAT IS A MAJOR
TALKING POINT TONIGHT.
FOLLOWING A HIGH-LEVEL BRIEFING
FROM SOME OF THE COUNTRY'S TOP
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY TELLS
US FROM CAPITOL HILL APPARENTLY
MANY IN CONGRESS ARE NOT THAT
INTERESTED.
>> IN A ROOM BENEATH THE
CAPITAL, THE INTEL CHIEFS WHO
CAME TO DELIVER A CLASSIFIED
BRIEFING ABOUT ELECTION
INTERFERENCE THAT EVERY HOUSE
MEMBER WAS INVITED TO SHARE
THOSE SECRETS WITH A LOT OF
EMPTY SEATS.
>> I WOULD SAY WE HAD 40 OR SO
MEMBERS THAT ATTENDED.
>> THAT'S 40 OUT OF 428 MEMBERS
SERVING RIGHT NOW.
ONE THEORY: CONGRESS DIDN'T WANT
TO COMMUTE AN HOUR EARLY.
HOMELAND SECURITY CHAIRMAN WAS
SURPRISED SO MANY LAWMAKERS WHO
TALK ABOUT ELECTION INTERFERENCE
BLEW OFF THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE, FBI
DIRECTOR, AND DHS SECRETARY.
>> THE DEMOCRATS HAVE MADE THIS
SUCH A BIG ISSUE AND ASKED FOR
THIS BRIEFING FOR A LONG TIME
AND WE FINALLY SCHEDULE IT AND
IT'S CLASSIFIED AND 30 MEMBERS
SHOW UP.
>> EVERY MEMBER OF CONGRESS NOT
RETIRING IS UP FOR REELECTION
AND THE MIDTERMS BUT NONE ARE
KNOWN TO BE IN THE CROSS HAIRS
OF FOREIGN METALLURGIST.
>> RIGHT NOW WE HAVE NO INTEL
THAT THERE IS A PARTICULAR
INTEREST.
>> SECRETARY NIELSEN SAID CHINA
AND IRAN ARE CONSIDERED THREATS
TO ELECTION INTEGRITY BUT THAT
KIND OF INTERFERENCE THEY ARE
WORRIED ABOUT IN 2018 IS THE
SAME KIND ELECTED IN 2016 WHERE
BALLOTS AREN'T CHANGED BY SOCIAL
MEDIA IS MANIPULATED TO CAUSE
CHAOS.
>> I THINK WE REMAIN CONCERNED
CERTAINLY ON THE FOREIGN
INFLUENCE I'VE HEARD WE HAVE
SEEN THAT CONTINUALLY.
>> DETAILS LIKE THAT DID NOT
DAZZLE THE DEMOCRATS WHO DID
ATTEND.
>> I DIDN'T HEAR ONE BIT OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
THERE WAS NOTHING THAT I
COULDN'T HAVE READ IN
"USA TODAY" THAT WAS REVEALED.
SO THE FACT THAT THERE WAS A LOW
ATTENDANCE, IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> THIS WAS THE RARE
RUSSIA-RELATED EVENT ON
CAPITOL HILL THAT HAPPENED
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, SO IT'S
GOING TO BE VERY INTERESTING TO
SEE IF THE HUNDREDS OF LAWMAKERS
WHO DECIDED THEY DIDN'T WANT THE
CLASSIFIED UPDATE TODAY DECIDED
TO SHOW UP TO THE NEXT RUSSIA
HEARING WHERE THE CAMERAS ARE
ROLLING THE WHOLE TIME.
BRET.
>> Bret: PETER, MOMENTS AGO
THE HOUSE PASSED LEGISLATION TO
EASE BANKING RULES, ESSENTIALLY
A REFORM OF THE DODD-FRANK LAW.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE BILL
THAT'S ACTUALLY NOW HEADED TO
THE PRESIDENT'S DESK?
>> IT'S MAKING LIFE EASIER FOR
SMALLER BANKS IN THIS COUNTRY.
AFTER THE FINANCIAL CRISIS WITH
THE DODD-FRANK REGULATIONS, THE
FEDS PUT THE STRICTEST
REGULATIONS ON BANKS THAT WERE
WORTH $50 BILLION OR MORE.
THEY SAID THOSE BANKS ARE TOO
BIG TO FAIL.
THEY MUST BE REGULAR.
NOW TOO BIG TO FAIL IS BIGGER.
$250 BILLION, FIVE TIMES THAT
SIZE, IS NOW THE "TOO BIG TO
FAIL" THRESHOLD WHICH MEANS THAT
A LOT OF SMALLER BANKS ARE GOING
TO HAVE A LOT FEWER REGULATIONS.
THIS DOES NOT REPEAL DODD-FRANK
BUT IT DOES ROLLBACK A LOT OF
IMPORTANT REGULATIONS AND IT IS
THE RARE MEASURE THAT VERY